y
[Música]
tras la muerte del ex presidente francés
valéry giscard están como consecuencia
del cobi 19 los homenajes se siguen
multiplicando fiscal que había sido
hospitalizado por su contagio en los
últimos meses modernizó la política y la
sociedad francesa en la década de 1970
enlazamos a parís
incluye hoy en venezuela la campaña
electoral rumbo a las legislativas del
domingo sin el grueso de la oposición
los partidos mayoritarios contrarios al
gobierno de nicolás maduro no
participarán en los comicios porque
denuncian falta de garantías tenemos
reporte desde caracas
es el día internacional de las personas
con discapacidad declarado en 1992 por
la 1 para promover los derechos de los
que tienen capacidades diferentes
hablaremos con una integrante de la red
latinoamericana de organizaciones no
gubernamentales de personas con
discapacidad
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
salgan a austria y hoy que es 3 de
diciembre sean bienvenidos empecemos en
francia
valéry giscard es tan expresidente
francés entre 1974 y 1981 falleció a los
94 años a causa de el coronavirus y scat
fue en su momento el jefe de estado de
francia más joven y tras dejar el cargo
una de las voces más escuchadas de la
vida política francesa el mandatario
llama noel macrón destacó su carácter
reformista por el que señaló se
transforma a francia al modernizar la
función del jefe de estado la asamblea y
el senado que se encontraban reunidos en
el momento del anuncio del fallecimiento
guardaron un minuto de silencio es por
ello que enlazamos a parís con erika
olavarría te saludamos por allá en la
capital nuevamente erika la mayoría de
las personas destacan la importancia del
fallecido ex presidente en la
construcción europea cómo reacciona el
continente a la muerte del ex mandatario
francés
efectivamente muy importante alan
recordemos que estuvo en el origen del
consejo europeo de la unión monetaria
como la conocemos hoy fue uno de los
propulsores del voto universal en el
parlamento europeo y una vez que salió
de la presidencia y pasó al parlamento
europeo él fue uno de los constructores
de la unión política que nunca
finalmente fue realizada en la unión
europea' angela merkel dice alemania ha
perdido a un amigo y recordemos que fue
giscard está en quien puso a la pareja
franco-alemana en el centro de la
construcción europea la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen él
dice en el corazón de giscard están los
destinos de francia y de europa estaban
unidos y obviamente desde el presidente
del consejo europeo también viene un
recuerdo para giscard d'estaing dijo él
creó el consejo europeo que sentó las
bases de la unión monetaria europea como
la conocemos hoy en día
alan tras la muerte del ex presidente de
francés los homenajes se siguen
multiplicando erika además del minuto de
silencio en el parlamento que actos se
esperan
el más importante a la nova ya las 8 de
la noche el presidente emmanuel macrón
va a hablar en cadena nacional para
recordar a valéry giscard d'estaing como
ya lo hizo cuando falleció por jacques
chirac
recordemos que debido a este discurso ha
tenido que suspender una entrevista que
iba a dar al medio de internet brutten
que iba a hablar sobre la situación de
la juventud en la pandemia y sobre las
polémicas y violencias policiales que
han despertado la ira de los ciudadanos
franceses sino císcar de estaña había
pedido a su familia un funeral discreto
en el círculo privado solamente en
familia y es lo que ha dicho su familia
que va a respetar esa última voluntad
también pidió ser enterrado en el jardín
de su casa cerca de tur su casa de campo
pero eso todavía no se sabe si va a
ocurrir pues se necesita una
autorización la familia quería construir
una capilla funeraria dentro de la
propiedad alan erika olavarría muchas
gracias por tu reporte desde parís
conozcamos más de valéry giscard están
el hombre que despenalizó el aborto y
rebajó la mayoría de edad a 18 años en
francia el ex presidente sólo cumplió un
mandato de siete años pero alcanzó a
llevar a cabo
y del cambio social en este país informe
de aurora
encarnó un cambio de época para la
quinta república parálisis cada stand
fue reconocido por haber dirigido la
modernización de la sociedad francesa
con tres socios
sé que hoy marca una nueva era para la
política francesa la del
rejuvenecimiento y el cambio para
francia
conocido por los franceses como bill por
sus iniciales en francés el presidente
emprendió rápidamente una serie de
cambios radicales como la reforma de la
mayoría de edad legal que pasó de los 21
a los 18 años pero quizás lo que más lo
destaca como un líder vanguardista fue
su labor en pro de la emancipación de la
mujer valerie hizo que el dinero pagado
por la píldora anticonceptiva fuera
reembolsable por el sistema de la
seguridad social también impulsó la
legalización del aborto su ministra de
salud y simón beige se encargó de luchar
por la defensa de la ley que fue
finalmente adoptada el 17 de enero de
1975 después de una amarga lucha
parlamentaria además fue bajo su mandato
que se aprobó la ley que introdujo la
noción de consentimiento mutuo en el
divorcio
anteriormente las solicitudes debían
basarse en una falta cometida por uno de
los dos cónyuges sin embargo el
presidente moderno de francia no se
atrevió a tocar la pena de muerte aunque
declaró su profunda aversión hacia la
pena capital
en venezuela concluye hoy la campaña
electoral rumbo a las legislativas del
domingo que no contarán con la
participación del grueso de la oposición
el gobierno de nicolás maduro convocó a
estas elecciones para renovar la
asamblea nacional pero los partidos
mayoritarios contrarios al chavismo no
podrán participar porque un fallo legal
les quitó las tarjetas electorales juan
guaidó insta a los ciudadanos a rechazar
las parlamentarias que el líder opositor
y 37 organizaciones más que lo apoyan
consideran fraudulentas hablábamos con
nuestra corresponsal en caracas quien
nos adelantó que se tiene preparado para
esta jornada
buenos días al anzhi fue un tierno
típico de campaña electoral debido a la
pandemia del cob y 19 los candidatos
comenzaron desde el 30 de noviembre a
hacer su cierre en la parte de opositora
que está yendo a estas elecciones lo
hizo en pequeños salones de hoteles
donde nos reunieron más de 100 personas
sin embargo el partido unido socialista
de venezuela si son los eventos con más
despliegue por todo el país el más
grande fue el día de ayer en el estado
de la guaira que queda a unos 30
kilómetros la ciudad capital donde uno
de los candidatos banderas
nicolás ernesto maduro que es el hijo
del presidente nicolás maduro hizo un
cierre con un evento grande con tarima y
con cantantes nacionales internacionales
donde ha grupo al menos a unas 2.000
personas hoy 3 de diciembre es el día
internacional de las personas con
discapacidad declarado en 1992 por la
asamblea general de las naciones unidas
con el propósito de promover los
derechos y el bienestar de las personas
con capacidades diferentes
es por ello que enlazamos con rosario
galarza integrantes de la junta
directiva de la comisión de damas
invidentes del perú y de la red
latinoamericana de organizaciones no
gubernamentales de personas con
discapacidad y sus familias señora a
galarza gracias por esta comunicación
hablemos de la discapacidad en tiempos
de pandemia cuál ha sido la respuesta en
américa latina' las medidas que los
gobiernos están implementando para
enfrentarse a la crisis incluyen las
necesidades de esta población
muchas gracias por la invitación el
nombre de la red latinoamericana de
organizaciones no gubernamentales de
personas con discapacidad y familias
para la cual trabajó como oficial de
derechos humanos en realidad las medidas
han sido muy poco incluyentes se ha
tratado de responder rápidamente en la
pandemia entiendo yo que es porque
ningún gobierno estaba preparado pero
también creo que es momento de comenzar
a pensar estas medidas han evidenciado
por ejemplo la falta de datos
desglosados por discapacidad por lo cual
muchas veces no se ha podido dar una
respuesta oportuna a la necesidad de las
personas con discapacidad sin embargo
algo también muy importante es que
sociedad civil ha podido también
manifestarse expresar pronunciamientos y
también colaborar para que esta pandemia
trate de que estas barreras no sean
demasiadas a las personas con
discapacidad sin embargo existe todavía
un riesgo de que todos los derechos que
sean conquistados al momento pueden
retroceder y por lo tanto tenemos que
trabajar mucho en esta etapa de
reactivación con reconstrucción
precisamente en señora galarza que deben
priorizar los gobiernos y los
involucrados para mejorar la situación
de las personas con capacidades
diferentes
lo que hay que progresar en el caso de
personas con discapacidad hay que hablar
de un enfoque de doble vía primero poner
en el centro el modelo social de
derechos humanos en la cual se incorpore
decir se transversales en la
discapacidad en todos los ámbitos
sociales educativos de empleo de salud
pero a la vez se hagan intervenciones
específicas porque hay necesidades
específicas propias de las personas con
discapacidad se debe garantizar la
accesibilidad de la información en todo
formato en todo momento y sobre todo
necesario mecanismos de consulta para
que las personas con discapacidad
podamos participar desde el diseño
evaluación implementación de toda
política y programa social rosario-
galarza muchas gracias por sus palabras
y está la comunicación ella es
integrante de la red latinoamericana de
organizaciones no gubernamentales de
personas con discapacidad y sus familias
más de 60 y 45 millones de personas han
resultado contagiadas por el coronavirus
a nivel mundial y cerca de un millón y
medio han muerto por la pandemia veamos
más noticias que deja el kobe 19 en esta
jornada
colombia reporta un 9 mil 297 casos
nuevos de coronavirus y 183 muertos
totalizando ya 37 mil 617 fallecimientos
desde que llegó el virus a territorio
colombiano el país es el décimo a nivel
mundial con más contagios acumulados el
noveno país con más contagios también es
sudamericano argentina superó del
miércoles las 39 mil muertes por el
coronavirus en las últimas 24 horas las
autoridades confirmaron 228
fallecimientos y 7 mil 533 nuevos casos
en el país casi todo el territorio
argentino está en distanciamiento social
obligatorio
lucia reporta más de 28 mil casos nuevos
de coronavirus y suma 500 54 muertos con
lo que el cuarto país con más casos en
el mundo rompió su récord diario de
contagios rusia comenzará la próxima
semana la vacunación de swift budnik ve
esto a gran escala que será gratuita
para la población y tendrá carácter
voluntario
o nos otros temas en hong kong el
empresario prodemocracia de los medios
de comunicación jimmy light de 71 años
fue acusado de fraude por un tribunal
local y permanecerá en prisión
preventiva hasta que la corte dicte una
sentencia al magnate de la prensa hong
kong esa se le acusa de defraudar a una
empresa gubernamental al incumplir un
acuerdo de alquiler de terrenos ayer
joshua wong
el activista más conocido de las
protestas a favor de la democracia
hongkonesa fue condenado a 13 meses y
medio de cárcel junto a otros dos
activistas
y pasamos a noticias de israel porque
casi siete meses después de establecer
una coalición
las diferencias entre benjamin netanyahu
y benny gantz se acercan al punto de
ruptura los dos hombres están en
desacuerdo sobre el presupuesto de este
año y las cosas se han puesto tan tensas
que el legislativo aprobó un movimiento
preliminar para disolver el parlamento
el primer ministro israelí llamó a guns
a impedir unos nuevos comicios
una coalición congelada codo con codo
pero sin mirarse la discordia entre
benjamin netanyahu y beni cant era
palpable en el parlamento con el
ministro de defensa dando la espalda al
primer ministro durante la votación del
primer paso para disolver el parlamento
y por lo tanto su acuerdo de reparto del
poder
benny ganz a favor benjamin netanyahu en
contra pero la disolución del parlamento
no es un hecho todavía se necesitan dos
votos adicionales dando a los políticos
israelíes tiempo para tratar de limar
sus diferencias la principal por el
momento es el presupuesto de israel para
2020 una vez en diciembre si el
presupuesto no está aprobado por el
parlamento es automáticamente disuelto
de todos modos cannes cuyo partido ha
caído en las encuestas podría perder su
reparto de poder establecido con una
nueva elección pero si la cuestión es
seguir adelante más temprano podría ser
mejor que tarde dicen que netanyahu ha
estado obstaculizando el trabajo del
gobierno y está buscando una nueva
elección a pesar de su voto en contra
una elección en la primavera post kobe
podría significar un parlamento más
amigable para netanyahu uno que podría
darle inmune
en un próximo juicio por corrupción
todos sabemos la verdad tú sabes la
verdad si no hubiera un juicio habría un
presupuesto si no hubiera un juicio
habría un gobierno que funcionaría
habría unidad
pero para netanyahu canses quien está
haciendo difícil obviamente en momentos
dramáticos como estos no necesitamos ir
a las elecciones el pueblo de israel
quiere unidad no votaciones quiere
vacunas no anuncios de campañas es una
compleja situación política que
significa que los israelíes podrían
volver a las urnas por cuarta vez en
menos de dos años en información
deportiva dos días después de haber
impuesto una sanción histórica a tres
jugadores de la selección argentina de
rugby incluido el capitán la unión
argentina de este deporte dio marcha
atrás y levantó el castigo a los
jugadores que publicaron comentarios
racistas y xenófobos en las redes
sociales sin embargo estos integrantes
no gran parte de la delegación que
jugará el sábado contra australia en el
torneo tres naciones
la navidad está a la vuelta de la
esquina es por ello que finalizamos en
eeuu con el encendido del árbol de
navidad en el centro rockefeller con
medias sanitarias por el cómic 19 lo que
suele ser una escena multitudinaria
repleta de turistas este año estuvo
cerrado al público el encendido de las
luces navideñas del árbol de 23 metros
de altura se transmitió por televisión
los dejamos con estas coloridas imágenes
siga con más en rands 24
[Música]
transmite